[Applause]
six days of tension finally erupts
[Applause]
not even the harmony of the choir could
keep the peace
[Applause]
a moment of contention that many had
anticipated and feared in the most
formal environment
and streamed live to the nation
they're taking out people who are being
who are basically clearing out iebc
election commission property
and every time they take on someone
who's riled up the crowd or has caused
any sort of chaos the people from ruto's
party are cheering them on
[Applause]
force was met with force
[Applause]
public tallies have shown a win for the
current deputy president william ruto
for days now
but supporters of his opponent and
former prime minister royal odinga
flagrantly rejected the vote count
and just moments before the outcome was
to be declared
drama spilt outside the tallying center
protests raged in odinga's nairobi
stronghold kibera
and four out of seven electoral
commissioners disavowed the tallying at
the last moment deeming it opaque
but none of that could stop ruto's
moment
finally announced as kenya's fifth
president
[Applause]
and as he took his victory lap his
opponent's running mate shared her views
online martha carua just tweeted it's
not over
until it's over
how will you respond to a contested
election outcome
this election to the best of our
knowledge and understanding
is over
we are a democratic country
we have built robust
institutions
that
can
undertake
the resolution of any issue
after months of campaigns and rallies
the climactic election announcement did
little to bring closure
it seems
that the race is far from over
just
sky news nairobi